laissez moi vous présenter les échos ce
prime ça d'amazon sur des lunettes
connectés alors regardez je monte très
rapidement vous allez avoir de l'audio
écouter de la musique de sa côte est des
petits boutons commandes tactiles dont
évidemment sur tout ce qui est
intéressant ici pour vous en avez envie
d'être de soleil d'une est normal ce qui
est intéressant c'est qu'en fait c'est
de là l'ex a les mains libres vous
baladez vous êtes toutes vos commandes
vocales passer des coups de fil alors le
l'idée est pas toute nouvelle mais en
tout cas et c'est ce qui est intéressant
c'est que c'est alex a directement
partout avec vous sur votre tronche donc
lhi déjà trop marrante quitte moi ce que
vous en pensez à ce que ça pourrait vous
tentez vous beauté ou alors pas du tout